[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are gonna be talking about Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez and she just visited San
Francisco a couple days ago we got some
really solid footage of the event and we
are going to be talking about her
playing the footage talking about her
thoughts her ideas and how we can just
enrich humanity together for those that
don't know Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
she's currently 28 years old she's a
politician educator organizer political
activist on June 26 of this year she won
the Democratic primary in New York's
14th congressional district defeating an
incumbent his name was Joe Crowley in
what was described as the biggest upset
victory in the 2018 midterm election
season and she's also a member of
Democratic socialists of America and has
been endorsed by various political
progressive organizations in individuals
so without further ado we're gonna go
ahead and start playing the video from
her in San Francisco we're gonna pause
throughout and we're going to talk about
what we learn and unpack it in for their
detail let's do it he's a pretty big
audience a couple hundred people
and Jane Kim from San Francisco who's on
the Board of Supervisors introduced
Alexandria
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
earlier today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
alright so there's a couple things to
unpack here that I think are really
important the first thing to unpack is
that it's very it's very interesting
that the way that the way that she's
describing the watch what's going on to
her right now
so it shouldn't be low the way that
she's describing what's going on with
her can you hear me better now okay look
okay well this is really this is
important stuff so stay with us here
alright so the way though she's
describing what's going on with her
right now is really important because we
don't typically think about what it's
like to go from bartending a couple
months ago
to being to being a political activist
to that that is that fills a theater
across the country so and at a young age
at 28 so she's she's walking us through
a very kind of like emotional experience
of what that's actually like and there's
no way to really prepare for that when
you wake up in the morning cnn's writing
about you and you're like whoa like i
don't know what to do this is crazy
stuff i need to figure out how to best
handle this totally real and raw and
interesting in that sense now just some
something from my perspective here is
that the stories about like you know
being at the shoe store and the person
going like oh my god it's you and stuff
these are fine stories to tell this
person saying oh you're Puerto Rican etc
like these are fine but these precious
minutes I mean you only have minutes on
stage here in San Francisco we want to
know how you're going to pay for
everything that you want to pay for
that's the truth this is why I think
that of having a moderator or an
interlocutor on stage with her that can
at least press in the sense of being
like okay Alexandra you have this policy
you want better you want healthcare for
people how do we pay for health care for
people does that come out of the
military budget does that where does it
come out of and how do you how do you
how do you teach people that it's
totally fine that we decrease military
budget in favor of healthcare and all
these different sort of ways of
understanding if you want to
pay for basic Community College for
people how are you going to pay for the
basic Community College so this is just
a blanket statement around the precious
time that you have on stage and just
being pressed if you want to lead and be
a leader in the sense of being able to
pull people from all these different
walks of life for them to understand
then you have to be more nuanced you
have to be willing the emotional stories
are important but also the story about
how you're actually gonna pay for the
things that you're promising we need it
this is kind of what I'm gonna talk a
little bit about the idea of a mono
culture and identity and the identity
politics here but especially with mono
cultures this exact same thing is
happening somewhere in Nebraska where
it's only a bunch of conservatives and
that it's just a monoculture of
conservatives as well and if there was
somebody on stage to press the
conservative a bit more in the liberal
or socialist sort of tendencies then the
it would be a better event in in
Nebraska as well so I'm just saying here
it would be a better event if there was
somebody on stage to press her a tiny
bit and how would you pay for these
things so that's what I think is
dangerous about monocultures and there
was definitely a monoculture here and
you'll see that a little bit more in the
video as we go but that this is these
are just some initial thoughts go it
let's go ahead and play again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
alright go ahead and pause Ronnie
alright so as you guys heard there there
was a chant that was going on from
Palestine to Mexico all the walls have
got to go and this is very interesting
because there is a well first of all
it's the first time I've ever heard that
chant the second thing is that and
probably many of us who haven't heard
that chant before but from a perspective
of like you know you look at the Earth
from the moon and you don't see any
borders you see all all the 100 billion
people that have ever lived and died
have lived and died right there on the
pale blue rock and that it's really
important to figure out how to work
together and so these so-called massive
walls and these military systems that
are protect these walls national
boundaries are definitely some things
that are probably going to slowly
dissipate over time as we globalize and
this is an important point and but at
the same time we have to realize that
this is not something that can just
dissipate tomorrow
you can't just tear down the walls
across borders tomorrow and let the free
flow of people go it's not that's it
because it's gonna be a lot of chaos
that occurs from doing that so I just
want to be clear here right now instead
of saying something along the lines of
yeah that's so true that all the walls
have got to go there could be this so
much nuance that's brought forward and
educated on to people about how yeah in
the short term let's let's figure out
how to best work together across borders
and then over time as we globalize and
work together as a planet we will slowly
dissipate these walls so there's got to
be more nuance here anyway let's go back
to the video
I wish you could have had the
conversation right then and there saying
it's important to have it the lighting
we have it right that you know this is
why monologues are more dangerous than
when you can have an interlock er there
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's give the cook pause okay this
pause is really quick because this is I
think one of the reasons why she's
resonating a lot with lots of Democrats
and socialists is because it is
absolutely absurd that people are
getting paid so little and we've seen so
many videos circulating across employees
of Amazon employees of Microsoft
employees sorry of Walmart employees for
different especially massive retail
chains and whatnot that are just getting
paid very very little money and barely
enough money that they can only live in
their car that they can't pay their rent
that they can't have health care like
she said and that this is one of the
things that really resonates with people
and this is something that really
resonates with me as well is I do think
that it unlocks human creativity when
people don't have to be scavengers for
the bare minimum jobs and that aren't
meaningful to them and that they can't
take care of their health as well all
this different kind of stuff so I think
that's one of the reasons why she's
really kind of making a tight grab onto
people's hearts and also that this whole
idea of these like racing for trillion
dollar companies the idea that we're
racing for trillion dollar companies
meanwhile this so-called we care so much
about our fellow sisters and brothers
but we don't at the same time when we're
not respecting the fact that the
employees that are working in Amazon
districts distribution centers are
struggling to pay for their rent so and
they have to live in their car so let's
just really unpack that conversation of
in all of its nuance like go for the
trillion dollar companies but also
figure out how to properly take care of
people and then well and then we'll
tackle egregious student debt we don't
need hundreds of thousands of dollars of
student debt anymore we got to figure
this out there's a better way to do this
so let's go ahead and play the video
again so good
[Applause]
three ways and in the society
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
injustice is a humanitarian issue not a
partisan one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's pause it quick
so this idea that that people need to
vote you know Bernie Sanders said it
that voting is not a spectator sport
participating in politics is not a
spectator sport it's something that you
need to go and educate yourself about
and then participate in the election and
if somebody needs to light a little fire
under your ass or a big fire under your
ass when you go and you read about
different candidates and you read about
what they care about what they're
representing you to do then you need
then then sure then this is correct that
if people are not going and voting
because nobody's knocked on their door
and told them hey this is how you learn
about politics and this is how you vote
in elections then we need to go and
knock on those people's doors that are
in cases privilege of people as are
people of color people that are a black
or Hispanic or what from wherever they
are and even white people that also are
not participating in voting that maybe
have progressive belief sets or that
might have conservative maybe some black
or Hispanic have conservative belief
sets really it doesn't really matter at
this point it's more about actually
activating and unlocking people's
attention to be focused more on reading
and learning and then making decisions
about how their government and country
operates on a small scale and a larger
scale and then the largest federal scale
as well I mean this is not a spectator
sport this is something that everybody
needs to be doing and no more
suppression no more suppression it's
time to unlock everyone's creative
ability we're good man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
posit please okay
we had a couple things there again as an
interlock here someone's got to push
back a little bit how do you structure
federal jobs guarantee what does that
look like how do you pay for health care
for everybody what does that look like
how do you pay for a universal basic
income for people what does that look
like how do you pay for education for
people what does that look like in all
of its nuance in all of its nuances
distributed to people how does this
affect the economy how does this affect
the basic person that is receiving these
Goods all of this has to be unpacked and
it's just not being unpacked here in
these monologues and and it's too bad
that people that are also in the
audience in this case just like they
would be in Nebraska are just listening
to the monologue and going yes yes yes
but then we got to talk about the nuance
of how it actually happens and this is
why it's important to have an
interlocutor here all right go ahead and
play again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna grill the pot you gotta keep
hot for you
we know this on the program we don't
just fall down and play down and get
back
[Applause]
[Applause]
alright I'll do it this pause ROM two
things there again saving the planet
okay we know a lot of Democrats and
socialists are gonna rally together to
talk about saving the planet and we know
about how important it is to sustain
earth over long periods of time how do
we do that
how do you plan to save the earth again
unpack the nuance here what are you
gonna do as we burn all of this energy
every single day as the United States
only 5% of the population on planet but
25% of the energy consumption on the
planet so how exactly are we going to do
that as we transition to renewables over
time and then the other things
immigration you know we solve health
care we create health care we create
immigration okay how woody what are you
gonna do about immigration how do we
figure out how to properly bring in
people from old from that come into the
United States as immigrants and properly
screen them to make sure that
everything's okay with them in terms of
their previous like record if they're
felon or not and also if they have
proper like mental ability or not all
this type of stuff so how do we figure
out how to properly do that and this all
needs to be unpacked and it's in all of
its nuance and it's not just a binary
thought process go ahead and play again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we pause it so so just a quick just
quick thought here is that it there's
just two things here it's that she's
right about like it can just be
scratched back scratch back and that's
like the only way to do things is that
if you actually see somebody that is
literally hurting that we got to figure
out how to help that that isn't as human
being that is that is a collective
system of people and stuff and so we've
got to figure out how to do that and
maximize the potential so they can get
on their own feet and also flourish
etcetera and then without expecting
something in return although we know
that as they creatively flourish that
the that the whole will all prosper in
that sense and then this others thought
it is it's actually true that these
places are different from each other
like Bronx is a lot different from
Birmingham in many ways and Detroit and
st. Louis in many ways just like San
Francisco is like a 99% liberal
monoculture and that is much different
than Lincoln Nebraska is and perming him
Alabama these are just facts so even
though humans are generally the same
like cognitive biological creatures they
do
outch on to biases assorted with
different thought processes and
political parties which then further
bias them in these monocultures so in
order to actually unpack the nuance we
got to be talking about although all of
the variables on all these issues in
depth and so they are similar but also
very different in many ways and so again
it's about the nuance not about the
binary let's play again
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so that's that's the extent of
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez visiting San
Francisco and giving her talk and extent
of you know our thoughts on her talk
again just some of the ideas about you
know expanding the electorate getting
people out to vote that are typically
not voting that are not educating that
previously weren't educating themselves
but now we are figuring out how to
educate them and get out to go vote on
these topics and expanding that that's
great we need to get more people out and
educated and voting on these topics also
we need to figure out how to properly
maximize and unlock the human creativity
potential that exists within people that
are currently stressed out working at
jobs they don't love working two jobs
that they have hundred thousand dollars
in debt that they don't have basic
health care that they can't access
collegiate level things that these
things need to be unlocked and created
somehow in the world but we have to
unpack the nuance about how to save the
planet provide healthcare drop the
borders we have to talk about the short
term the long term we've talked all the
nuance in-between
that's why remember interlocutors that
are Polymathic that our economist that
are multidisciplinary that are good
active listeners paraphrase errs all
this is so important at these events
whether it's the monoculture here in the
Bay Area at this event and democratic
socialist perspective or the monoculture
in Nebraska where it's a bunch of
conservatives also gathering together
so remember interlocutors are crucial
moderators people to have all this
nuance around the discourse thanks
everybody for tuning in
we greatly appreciate if you guys had a
good time subscribe comment below we'd
love to hear from you build this
community
join us on patreon so we can continue
going to great places like this and
capturing the content and talking about
it and enriching us to move forward
collectively and figure out all this
great content thanks to Ron our producer
and director much love everyone peace
[Music]
you